hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are continuing
with the match Magnus Carlsen versus
onigiri now we left it off at game 2
where Geary won the game with the black
pieces it was it was quite quite the
game so if you haven't check it out make
sure you do
and then in game 3 gear it was a game 3
ended in a draw but gear was much better
for the entire game and then in the end
he made one inaccuracy he captured on g6
instead of pushing the point to h6 and
that resulted in arm well in the drone
end game did Magnus was Indian trying to
win but it ended in a draw so now
gearing needs to survive this he only
needs a draw to win the match and Magnus
says the white pieces so let's see what
happened
Magnus opens with E for this time as he
needs a win sorry about that
we have c5 by giri going for the
Sicilian defense and now Knight to f3
now we have d6 d4 C captures Knight
captures and Knight to f6
we have Knight to c3 and the Giri goes
for the knight of defense so we're very
exciting that in a in a game where
Magnus has to win with the white pieces
Giri chooses the denied earth with
Bishop to g5 by Carlsen East 6 and now
f3 and just strengthening the e4 pawn
with Bishop to e7 and the Queen to d2 in
our Magnus prepares to Castle queenside
assault both players castle with castles
castles and now b5 by Erie starting his
expansion on the Queen side preparing
bishop to be 7 and so on the night is
coming to c5 the rookies coming to c8
the usual neither stuff so a3
preventing before and now Bishop the b7
and here there are there are a lot of
moves that you can play here but King to
be one in this exact same position that
Carlsen place is a new move so as a move
11 we have a completely new game and
every continues with Knight B to d7
we have Quinta II won now by Magnus
which will which you can use to ship the
Queen over to the King side if needed
and also to support the e4 pawn if
needed so rook the c8 and Gary continues
with the usual night of stuff and now
Magnus starts pushing with h4 we have
Queen to c7 and
standard night of move and now rook the
h3 by Magnus a nice replicating the rook
away from this diagonal well basically
from the h1 square so he can start
pushing on the Kings side and just here
rook ft 8 by giri and here Magnus goes
with the h5 move a bit to do quickly now
not maybe not a bit too quickly but
maybe he should have realized that the
bishop on g5 is undefended so although
you can just play h6 here and kick back
the bishop here Giri just goes for
Knight captures on e4 as all trades are
going in his favor so now your bishop is
under attack twice as it's undefended so
you are kind of forced to capture on e7
so Magnus do goes Ford will the shop
capture Sonny 7 Knight captures and c3
now with check by Geary
B captures on c3 and now rook captures
on e7 and now Magnus not not in a great
spot especially since you need to win
the game however he does have this
Knight to f5 which he plays now attacks
the rook here problem is if you go back
with the rook just Knight captures here
you grab upon and you will win another
rook
well one of the rooks so instead Gary
just grabs the knight and offers up the
rook this way so the Queen leaves her
defense of the c3 pawn so the black
queen can capture so Queen captures on
e7 we have Queen captures and c3 now by
Gary and now Bishop to d3 a defending
the c2 pawn and now hoping to create
some threats on the King side if
possible but Aguirre immediately jumps
in with the knight Knight the c5 now
that the night is and c5 also the bishop
on b7 is guarded and now you are of
course also threatening just captures
here which will weaken the c2 pawn so
Magnus doesn't allow this trade he plays
Bishop captures an f5 and now we reach
the position from the thumbnail it's
black to move and remember Gary only
needs the draw to win the game so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the move that giri played while i give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting this tricky
line and for the
you just want to enjoy the show Giri
played night to be three nights the a
for works with a similar idea but we're
going with the mood that give replayed
which just immediately threatens made
from a four you will also threaten made
here but here it's just it's just it's
just way more cool since you're also
offering up both the denied the bishop
and so on so here if you don't want to
get checkmated what are your options
here well you could consider capturing
the night however if you capture the
night then you're getting made at Queen
captor Sun be three King gay one now you
part with the rook and after wherever
you go with the King doesn't really
matter a king to be two you're gonna get
Queen c1 check an hour after King b3
Bishop the d5 check the King has to go
up the board and now Queen to d2 will be
made as the bishop covers b3 so that's
one of the mating patterns but there are
a lot more obviously depending on what
Carson would play so here a constant
doesn't capture instead he moves the
king now the rook guard the a1 square so
there is no checkmate and also the Queen
moves you can also pick up the night
maybe with the king but now Gary finds a
second move which is also very very very
nice Bishop d5 is an option but here it
goes for him for the much more forcing
one night the c1 with check again
doesn't give cost in a move so you
either pick up the night and allow a
perpetual because the rook for the
moment guards the defog square however
if you capture it then you allow Bishop
to b5 checked and now you don't really
have anything King captures here Queen
captures on a3 and it's very unlikely
that you will be able to escape a
perpetual and also there are they're
just the mating threat of Queen Queen to
a2 so we'd have to go for c4 and so on
but it would just be very ugly Queen b3
check it doesn't really matter if if
black has a win or not because you only
need a perpetual here with best defense
it is it is a draw but still now you're
only looking for ways to draw so here of
course and repeated King to be won but
now Knight back to b3 by Gary again
repeating the position to create some
mating threats with Queen to a-1 King to
a2 by Magnus and now again night at the
c1 with check King b1 and now
nice to be three we already said what
happens if you capture the night and it
was in this position that the first
agreed to a draw or rather it's a draw
by threefold repetition so by by winning
Game two and the drawing games three
four and one and Geary wins the match
against Carlsen and what this will do to
the standings well quite a lot it
actually bring against the throws Giri
back into the into the game so he
perhaps could also still be fighting for
the top four places I don't know if I
mentioned this but these are only the
preliminaries so for the top four
players of this tournament will play a
knockout tournament after this one
finishes so this is basically like
similar to the Grantchester and then
after that you have the London chess
classic which has only four players but
yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be really
exciting to see what what giri will do
now that he defeated Magnus Carlsen
we're probably gonna hear a lot about it
on Twitter for for forever but it should
do wonders for the tournament yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoy it
congratulations once again to everyone
who found the night to be three idea I
would like to thank a man LaGuardia
Michael Reid Chris Picard mark Gupta and
Don Puri for your contribution to my
channel thanks a lot - really appreciate
it
as usual we can check - my previous
videos here thankful for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it finishes so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Sunday